another movie where the world is coming
to an end I don't think God likes us the
world's end when this movie started my
first reaction was the world may be
ending but the comedy is just beginning
this movie is hilarious here was being
most of the film comedy Simon [ __ ]
Pegg this guy rocked it in this role
what I really liked about this movie was
usually Simon Pegg and Nick Frost yeah
they're usually together but Nick Frost
is usually just some type of a sidekick
and he's only the 88 obnoxious one and
simon Pegg's more the subtle smarter one
and this one Simon Pegg he's more the
idiot he's one of the guy who's that you
know he's he's lost he's not just he's
really living in the past he has real
drinking problems and for some reason
the I found drinking problems to be
funny further changes ever just like
Jack Sparrow kids love the alcoholic
Jack Sparrow so I mean they love the
British actor Simon Pegg being an
alcoholic he's not just funny he really
gets to show that he has a heart he
managed to take this really obnoxious
over-the-top character and give him a
lot of heart another person who did a
really good job his buddy Nick Frost
Nick Frost I want him to lose weight
because just like heart disease out
there stuff like that and I I don't want
him to pass on early is so yes Nick
Frost being fat is funny but you can
lead to death earlier so please I don't
want your world to end up but Nick Frost
really good he doesn't play another
idiot this time it actually might be the
smartest one in the group and he is
really funny at the same time he has
sort of an an inner anger inside of him
someone who who was waiting to be
unleashed and it's not about taking out
on food it's about take it out on drinks
so he has a lot of drinking drinking is
like one of the themes of this film it's
nice to be in a movie again about
drinking the
not about marijuana don't worry there's
some marijuana references I can go for a
bowl right now but writing and directing
of this film is solid and go right if
you guys don't know this is like the
trilogy is the same people that made
Shaun of the Dead and Hot Fuzz now we
got the World's End and Edgar Wright huh
he did it right Ryan Wright likes Edgar
Wright cuz everything is right with
Edgar Wright and if Ryan Wright says so
it must be right this one has so many
charters it's like a reunion film it's
like a British comedy and then it's also
this crazy sci-fi fly what I loved about
it was it's like a build-up to the
science fiction story
it doesn't start off early and they
don't try to set up a tone for sci-fi
it's like I would probably feel in the
real world just having a normal dinner
holy [ __ ] bad shits going on with a
bunch of like aliens robots whatever the
[ __ ] is happening right now so at times
it's funny at times it's dramatic at
times of scary but overall it just has
this really big heart and they managed
to take all these genres and turn it
into like one nice film and it also has
really good cinematography to compliment
the whole story just the in Samba is
great all these actors working together
these like older British guys are so
[ __ ] funny British people are funny I
think British people can be funnier than
Americans
I don't think so British people are more
talented than Americans I think that's
why they cast British people to play
superheroes all the time not like Ben
Affleck is Batman ah yeah [ __ ] you Ben
Affleck is what everyone else is saying
not me I think is gonna do a good job I
don't think the world can hand over that
ha I referenced the
movie again by going off topic salt
acting salt riding saw directing salt
cinematography it's like a perfect end
to this trilogy you know many trilogies
just sucked by the time they get to the
third one or in case of like The Dark
Knight Rises where it gets great reviews
but most people seem to just [ __ ]
hate it for some reason this one I'm
pretty sure everyone well the majority
will be on board what I love about these
filmmakers is a managed to take genres
and then also add some comedy into it
they manage to tell these films that
honor those genres so well while still
providing the laughs my one complaint is
that it might be just Oh
little too long just a little bit but
other than that it's it's pretty much
perfect let me get straight to the point
here all you got see the world's end got
it super right alright guys see you
checking out a review for the World's
End why don't you go ahead skull that
comment box below and tell me what is
your favorite movie with Simon Pegg and
Nick Frost
you can include Paul or spaced you
probably won't and if you want to see a
more in-depth review of the World's End
go ahead and check out my show called
reasons to see that I do my buddy Jerry
that's Jerry right there he's got facial
hair say where I got a facial hair saw
my face that doesn't make any sense
buddy go ahead and follow me on Twitter
you look like right here I'll follow you
back sup man blossom at least you want
to get updated every time one of my
reviews is out good click on this button
on my penis's subscribe that's right
people the penis now what my world ends
mm-hmm it's where my world expands gets
bigger larger thicker I'm uncomfortable